[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Worship one God like Jesus did and all
the prophet before him. Well, the the
previous scripture like in Isaiah
29:112, Isaiah 42,
11:17, it's it's uh direct and light for
Gentiles, new song, new island, desert
town, people of Sa for joy. It give you
the location that in Arabia there will
be another prophet coming with with a
new song that mean different from the
the Hebrew. And this is Arabic. And this
is why uh we are cousin with the Jew. So
the Jew the Jews have their law 616 only
for the Jew. Why prophet Muhammad come
with confirmation for the law of of of
Moses and bringing a new law which shar
apply for all the kingdom of the all the
people on earth. And this is why prophet
Muhammad is the last revelation from
God. This is why Quran mentions that is
superior and surpass the Bible and
corrected and it corrected and chapter
2, chapter 3, chapter four and five it
answer all the quiry of the Jew and
Christian. Can I talk? Yeah, please.
All right. So, I I'll do it one point at
a time. Okay. you you brought up uh he
brought up Isaiah 42 and says that um a
prophet's supposed to come from Arabia
according to Isaiah 42. Okay. So my
question is this where in Isaiah 42 does
it say that a prophet is going to come
from Arabia. Okay. Uh it if you read it
42 from 117 uh uh verse number six a
light from Gentiles a new song you
island desert town. Yeah, you you can
check it on your own time. I'm going to
I know the verse. Yeah. Yeah. Go. Very
good. So, it just tells them to sing,
right? Very good. Uh and Islam
8446 blessed the one who dwell in your
home ever praising you. Ever praising
you. only the Muslim 24 uh 7 days uh
3365 day they circulating around the
praise and worshiping God and spirit and
obedience and this is only it happened
in
Islam I'm ready to give you
some I'm giving you I'm giving you your
own scripture which confirm what I'm I I
understand what you're saying, but my
question like it wasn't answered. My
question is where in Isaiah 42 does it
say that a prophet is going to come from
Arabia. Okay. Okay. You have you have uh
verse number number 10 the new song you
island that mean he will come from that
that place. It doesn't say that. No, it
does because Arabia uh uh
doesn't say that according to you. No,
no, no. You can you can choose whatever
you want. You have you have Deuteronomy.
You have Deuteronomy
18:18 prophecy from Moses. You have
Isaiah
29:112. You have Isaiah 67. You have 42.
You have Ezekiel
27:21. And this is
I need you to focus. Focus on Isaiah 42.
So look, this is what we're going to do.
I'm going to read it. Read it. Okay,
we're going to read 10 to 14 cuz that's
what you're talking about. Let me tell
you, I'll give you one one now. Isaiah
28:10, 111. We can talk about We'll talk
about that next, but specifically Isaiah
42. Okay. 42. Yeah. All right. Start
from number four and read. I'll start
from 10 cuz that's the that's to sing a
new song. Start from number four,
please. Four. Yeah. Yeah. You're a good
reader. All
right. So, this is what it says.
Tell them you're busy. I I just I am
busy. All right. Isaiah 42. Okay. We
start. Yeah. He will not grow, faint, or
be discouraged till he has established
justice in the earth and the
coastlands. Wait for his law. Thus,
okay, thus God Yahweh who created the
heavens and the earth, stretched them
out, who spread out the earth and and
what comes from it, who gives breath to
the people and spirit to those who walk
in it. I am the Lord. I have called you
in righteousness. I'll take you by the
hand and keep you. I'll give you as a
covenant to the people, a light to the
Gentiles. Stop here. Stop here. Uh can
you read it again this verse, please?
Yeah.
I will give you as a covenant to the
Gentiles. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. A
covenant to the people, a light for the
Gentiles. Thank you very much. Was is
Muhammad a covenant?
It's not a covenant and it's not not
confirming that people genize because as
as a prophet Jesus peace upon him said
only for the lordship of Isra and he he
command his apostle during his ministry
for three years not to go among gentile
or smart years. Yeah. And then he said
go out to all nations are baptized. This
is only about after the resurrection.
Exactly. So they had so they had they
had a mission and then he opened it up.
Right. Carry on. All right. So it says
that that this person here is a
covenant. Right. Carry on. Carry on. Is
that correct? Okay. Is Muhammad a
covenant? Carry on. Yes. Muhammad is a
covenant. I will tell you. Okay. Yes.
Can you show? All right. Look. Very very
simple. Very simple. Okay. Very simple.
So it says that this person is a
covenant. Let me give you an example of
what I'm looking for. Okay. Okay. Jesus
says in Matthew 26, he says, "This is my
blood of the covenant for the
forgiveness of sins." So Jesus claims
himself to be the covenant. that's being
given to the people. Can you show me in
the Quran or a Hadith? Wait, just listen
carefully cuz I No, no. I don't want to
go to another topic. Carry on. No, no,
no.
This will this will take us to another
subject.
All right. Let me let
me finish. When we finish, we'll come
back to this. I'm going to tell you why.
This is the exact subject we're talking
about. cuz you're you're saying that
Muhammad is mentioned in Isaiah 42. So
if the in Isaiah 42 the descriptions
about this this servant does not match
Muhammad, then he's eliminated. To be
real, he's eliminated at verse one.
Okay. But but I'm allowing this like
just for entertainment. Very kind. Thank
you. All right. So it says that he's a
you want to skip that come back to that
later. We come back to that. Okay. We'll
come back to that later. Okay. Okay. No
worries. He says we'll come back to this
later. I trust y'all here. Do you mind
if I go to 10? Carry on. No, carry on
from from 6 and carry on. Carry on
because it gives you the location. Oh,
that's that's not in that's not in
early. The locations are down 10 and
down. Can I just skip the 10 and down?
No. It doesn't give the locations here
in in verses six and down to nine. It
doesn't give locations.
After Please carry on, seven, eight.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Please. All
right. Verse seven. now to bring out I'm
sorry uh to open the blind eyes and to
bring out the prisoners from their
dungeons. Did Jesus open blind eyes? Did
Mhammed? No.
Oh. Okay. Um verse eight. I am the Lord.
That is my name. I am Yahweh. Sorry. I
am Yahweh. That is my name. Is Allah's
name Yahweh?
We can talk about Okay, we'll talk about
that later. Okay, we'll talk about that
later. Okay, my glory I give to no
other, nor my praise to carved idols.
Behold, the former things have come to
pass. A new thing, and new things I now
declare. Before they spring forth, I
tell you of them. So, it doesn't mention
the locations yet, remember? So, I was
trying to tell you this, but you didn't
want to listen to me. Now, verse 10.
Verse 10 is going to be where you want.
Okay. Fair enough. Okay. So, verse 10.
I'm trying to see what you're shaking.
All right. Sing to the Lord a new song,
his praise from the ends of the earth.
Okay. Okay. You who go down to the sea.
So that's location two. And all that
feels it. The coastlands, location
three. Okay. And all their inhabitants.
Let the deserts, location four, and its
cities lift up their voice. The villages
that Kadar inhabits. I'm going to count
that as the same. The wilderness, the
Kadar. I'm going to say that's the same
thing. Okay. Maybe that's fine. The
wilderness. the villages that Kadar
inhabits. Um, let the habitants of SA
sing for joy. That's location five.
Okay. Let them shout from the
mountaintops. Can we stop there? Yeah.
Carry on a little bit more. Yeah. A
little bit more. Okay. I'm just I'm just
waiting for where it says he's going to
come from any of these places. Okay.
Okay. Let them give glory to the Lord
and declare his praise in the
coastlands. The Lord goes out like a
mighty man, like a man of war. Can we?
It's enough. It's enough. Okay. Now, now
it's my turn. Wait. So, wait.
Specifically, specifically is my
question. Okay. Where where does it say
that the servant comes from any of these
places? Look, uh the servant of the
Lord, he come from let the wilderness
wilderness.
Where does it say that? Where is Kar?
Where is it? Wait, where is where is the
desert? Where is the top of where is the
prophet? He come he come everywhere all
they sing and joy where do where do they
sing for the Lord 3000 everywhere 165
everywhere from everywhere
as as as our forefather Abraham when he
establish when he
establish the foundation of Kaba he
called for everyone and you know that
from all around the earth they go to Haj
and they praise to in 10 days. This 10
days and this is exactly the proof that
prophet Muhammad is the covenant, the
new covenant after Abraham make covenant
with God. Okay. So, all right. So,
specifically specifically I want to see
cuz you said he comes from the
wilderness. Yeah. I'm about to read this
part about the wilderness. It
says, "Let the deserts and its cities
lift up their voice." Stop. Wait. Why?
Why he's talking about the I'll stop
I'll stop here. You're right. I'll stop
here. Good. Stop. Does it say that he
comes from the desert?
My question to
listen
listen. Let's cook together. Let me put
some spices. Let me put some spices.
Where does Muhammad come from? Oh my
gosh.
Desert. Mecca. Isn't that desert? Sure.
Now it become like city. Sure. Sure.
Sure. But but ya ya ya. Does it say now?
Be honest with me. Okay. I I am always
honest. Okay. I trust you. Does it say
that he comes from the desert and his
and it does it say that? No. He's
talking about desert.
Please just answer the question. Yes.
Yes. Does it say he comes from the
desert? No. He's talking about the
desert. I know. Does it say he comes
from the question?
Please ignore. Does it Does it say he
comes with us?
No. Does it say in the verse here? Look.
Does it say he comes from the desert and
the cities? Prophetically come from the
Does it say that? Does it say that? No.
[Applause]
No. Logically, logically and his dad
logic. He knows that the prophet come
from the desert, come from Arabia and
they are the descendant of Ishmael who
been kicked by by by Sarah and they go
and stay where they stay. Okay. All
right. I got you. Yeah, I got let's use
let's use God logic. Okay. So according
to what you're understanding because it
mentions the desert and its cities,
you're saying that the prophet comes
from the desert and its cities, right?
Okay. So let's follow this logic. Okay.
It
says, "Sing to the Lord a new song, his
praise from the end of the earth." Which
prophet came from the end of the earth.
No, he's not talking about the prophet.
It mentions itself, but it No, no, no.
Let me correct you. No, no, no. Please,
please, let
me say yeah, please let me tell you. Let
me just say this first and then we Oh my
goodness gracious. The new The new song.
The new song is the Arabic language the
Quran and which replace the
Judaism every Hebrew songs because in
Hebrew they used to praise God with
their song. There's a new sound, a new
nation, a new kingdom replacing the the
the kingdom of the Jew. People taken by
the Jews because of their disobeying to
Jesus because they tried to kill him.
This is what you need to use your
intellect and your logic come to
conclusion. God give us logic here.
Remember, let's use logic. God give us
intellect to analyze what we are talking
about. All right, I got you. So you said
again, let's just remind what we're
talking about. Okay. You said that
because it mentions the deserts and its
cities, that means the prophets coming
from there. Yes. Is the desert and the
cities the only place mentioned?
No. Everywhere. Okay. It mentions
everywhere. It mentions coastlands. It
mentions SA. It mentions the uh uh the
mountain tops. Okay.
So stop. Which prophet? Okay. Which
prophet comes from the ends of the
earth?
All the prophet and messenger we know
that they come from from the region of
Middle East. You don't forget that. What
prophet came from the coastlands?
Prophet
Muhammad come from Arabia. And I
said I don't know. Okay. I I'm not aware
of anyone coming from coastline because
we can we can we can say the coastline
of the Mediterranean Sea because all the
prophet and messenger come from
Palestine. Okay, I got you. So you you
don't you don't know which prophets came
from these places. But you're saying but
you do affirm do you affirm that when
all these places are mentioned it's
saying that prophets are coming from
these places? I just told you all the
prophet and messengers they come in the
bloodline of that's not what I asked bro
please. I'm lost now. Okay, I know
you're lost. I'm trying to help you. No,
no, I'm trying. I'm trying to help you.
Look, look. No, don't go anywhere else.
Don't go to Don't go to Genesis. Don't
go anywhere else, bro. Because you're
getting lost. Why you want to squeeze it
according to your Because you referenced
this. Okay. So, I'm sticking with what
you referenced. Okay. So, according to
your logic, because a place is
mentioned, that means that a messenger
is coming from that place. Okay. So that
means that according to how you're
interpreting this, a messenger has to
come from the ends of the earth. A
messenger has to come from the
coastlands. A messenger has to come from
SA. A messenger has to come from the
mountain tops. A message has to come
from Kadar. Right. Well, no. Because we
are talking about the servant of God. We
are talking. We are talking about the
servant of God. One, not everyone. Not
many prophet and messenger. Before you
shut to my my my bum now. Leave it. I'm
done. No, I am not done yet. That's it.
That's it. in Genesis. Genesis
31. This is the cornerstone. The
cornerstone which is in Arabia. The
cornerstone. Cornerstone. That's where
where the people go and obedience
shoulder to shoulder according to your
own Bible the 24 hours. Thanks for
coming. Thanks for coming.
Watch the
[Applause]
up. I want to say something
guys. Uh what we do here we are we will
be judged according to our saying and
deed. And I believe in God. I believe
that God is all forgiven, all merciful.
Uh and we whatever we say, we say for
the sake of God, any deceitful deceitful
tongue will be end up in hell fire. I
warn everyone and I ask everyone to
believe and and the God who you believe
that is only one according to all the
prophets and messenger.
Lord our God, even Jesus, he teach the
Lord our God is one. He didn't say three
and one or four and one or
Jesus is Lord. Thank you. Thank you.
Appreciate
it. Thanks for coming. If there's
anybody else that wants to step up for
the conversation, you guys can
also because I'm I know you you're
loaded. No.
Okay. Thank you. So, just to wrap up
guys, um he brought Isaiah 42 and
unfortunately we didn't get to see that
the prophet came from Arabia or the
coastlands or really anywhere. It just
tells them it just it just tells them it
just told them to sing a new song. And
why are the coastlands why are the
mountaintops why is the Jordan why
everywhere to the ends of the earth are
they singing a new song? is because of
the Messiah, the one who the spirit fell
upon. Verse one, I will put my spirit
upon him and he will preach and bring
justice to the Gentiles. It's because of
the of Jesus Christ that non-Jews along
with Jews have knowledge of the Lord
today. It's because of him that millions
and billions have come to the knowledge
of the true God, Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit. It's the Messiah who fulfills
this. He's the covenant who brought
forgiveness of sins. He's the one that
washed us clean when we didn't deserve
it. It's because of Jesus Christ. All
right.
It's God. It's God. It's God.
is God.